you know i'm trying to stay humble
because my wife keeps me humble but you
know
sometimes you got to talk that [ __ ] to
yourself sometime when i'm in the
sometimes when i'm when you know when
i'm at the house sometimes i'm hey [ __ ]
we having too much of this [ __ ]
sometimes you gotta tear yourself that
sometimes you gotta turn up sometimes
it's cool to be humble like i'm very
humble but sometimes i gotta
give myself a pat on the back and let
myself know hey hey gays [ __ ] we did it
cause i'm my own best friend and maybe
this come from doing a lot of time
juvenile detention to
to adult jail [ __ ] like that i'm always
by myself
so sometimes i like to pat myself on the
back and tell myself hey [ __ ] we did it
we having too much of this [ __ ] man but
that's your loser you're never by
yourself
right you know right now somebody
somebody's telling what's what you're
saying right at you and some something's
telling you to say that you're saying
that by yourself
yes system told you to say yes sir
you're not by yourself
like you know when i go to psychiatrists
they say do you hear voices
i want to say yeah [ __ ] i hear voices
but if you say that the [ __ ] goes to
all those people with the white jacket
and you're going to be [ __ ] up
but you know you hear voices
all geniuses talk to themselves like
talking to smart people
that's why right all geniuses talk to
themselves
most of the problems that i haven't
figured out that came from me talking to
myself and figuring it out
yeah i tell my wife why are you talking
to yourself i like to talk to small
people
okay oh genius
my kids are you talking to yourself my
kids are freaked out you talk to
yourself [ __ ] right
[ __ ] right that's how i got you all
this [ __ ] talking to myself i'm loud in
the bathroom who you talking to man it's
just me
your whole house is [ __ ] up
but they didn't get used to it though
because i walk around talking to myself
you talk to my kids you talk to yourself
get away from me sometimes when i'm
running on the treadmill i'm running on
the treadmill
doing a full speed sprinter i'll be like
come here [ __ ] don't you run from me
and it just
it just that's what motivated me to keep
going so it's just
my kids daddy you're talking or
something that runs for me
[Laughter]
you have full blown out conversations
mike with yourself dude
i like talking to intelligent people you
ever play out scenarios
like how you think things may go off no
i listen
i'm deep in there i know how it's gonna
go i don't even go to no scenario
i already be knowing like listen right
this is the deal with the most shrooms
right
i mean the worst thing for me to do is
be on shrooms alone but when you get
mushrooms alone
it [ __ ] with you tell your hope it
builds up your confidence ability it
makes you
good you feel like god and then they say
hey remember you did that thing to some
such and such before how do you think
about that you think that was really
nice
and he said whoa what's that about hey
remember you did that to certain
and yeah then i mean he was [ __ ] he
got the guilt trip on you like oh my god
i'm running my wife hey baby baby baby
come back come here yeah
she don't like me babe i'm sorry i did
shoes and it's [ __ ] with me but
there's balance
that's boundless that's balanced i'm
sure i'm gonna start getting my
my confidence something to say then
bring back the [ __ ] i used to do
the bad say why you do this like you
think that was cool
no but you think that's what you think
that's a bad thing mike no i think
i think um um what's the word i wanted
to use i think this
i think is such an evolving moment in my
life
dealing with who i am and not being
ashamed before i am
worried that's been my whole journey you
know not being ashamed of nothing
yeah he's just free mike yeah
it's just uh you know you don't belong
to a party
yeah how can i not be i i'm a republican
i'm a democrat
i'm everything how can i not be in a
party
yeah i'm here on earth i'm i'm politics
people up look the black community we
are politics how can you not be in
politics
your existence is politics yeah
no it is our existence of politics on
what somebody say this is our lifestyle
now
so you have to be a politic you have to
you are you are born of politics
[Music]